why why is it so hard to forgive
ourselves and why do we not even know
that we need to like I think that's even
a thing like I don't know do I need to
forgive myself for anything and and
there's such power in that you know have
you realized that there's anything you
need to forgive yourself for and what
was the what was what what was the
feeling why when what happened after
just what's coming to mind is like
growing up as an actor you audition for
something and you fail so many times you
get rejected Time After Time After Time
and
I didn't forgive myself in those moments
I rejected myself I beat myself up I
criticized myself I'm like you're you
know I've put in so much effort and I'm
getting so little return and I'm like oh
I'm a failure I'm wasting my 20s like
I'm not forgiving I I needed to forgive
myself in those moments I needed to
realize that like
so it's it's an energy of like releasing
the pressure off the valve and then you
show up in the world a lot more
confident present loose and people then
want to hire you whether you're an actor
or a plumber or anything else it's like
when we're so
punishing ourselves over and over for
little things that don't even matter to
the rest of the world of course bigger
things when you hurt someone or you
again because you haven't taken care of
yourself so you've reacted to something
you've let a trigger get the best of you
or you make a mistake you make bad
judgments
um you know
I just feel like we need to be given
we need to be taught how to forgive
ourselves and how important it is and I
feel like that's why we are in the state
we are today of this cancel culture
because we beat ourselves up so much and
we hold ourselves to this impossible
standard that
like we have to
beat other people up and condemn other
people because again there's this like
pressure valve of all these things we're
stuffing down that we haven't accepted
and we've been
hiding because we're so ashamed and we
haven't forgiven ourselves even though
again in the grand scheme of things
they're little things or the things that
we thought were so massive in childhood
um that were so devastating and
life-changing it was like not a big
thing but it held it down
turn the valve long enough those things
Fester those things get moldy those
things get compounded and so all of that
to say I think we need to learn to
forgive ourselves in the moment so that
we don't suppress so much shame and
guilt and and as we learn to do that to
ourselves I think we're going to live
and see and experience a much more
forgiving not cancer cultury
society and reality we're treating
ourselves that way which inevitably
means we treat others that way like what
we judge in ourselves we judge in others
so forgiveness for ourself is is the way
to start with it and I think that would
be a really powerful tool to transform
so many things going on
um I mean you know let's talk a little
bit about like masculine feminine I feel
like I'm always on this topic I'm very
curious about that you know we're
talking about forgiveness like you know
there's some I interview a lot of guys
these days and I'm really curious about
this patriarchy sort of theme I'm
curious about the masculine feminine
like I'm thinking do we forgive men for
being in power like what does that look
like and how how do we how do we forgive
ourselves for not standing I mean
there's also an equal and opposite like
we should forgive ourselves for not
standing up for ourselves in the past
right so what it what needs to come into
balance the masculine the me I'm just
going to use man and woman from the male
side and the female side what do you
think needs to be rectified because
again when we're turning the turning the
fingers back on ourselves as the the way
that things move forward and we are
talking about forgiveness another one is
unite I think another powerful tool to
balancing things out is this uniting of
the masculine and feminine within us so
what do you think is out of balance when
we're looking at generally speaking men
and women in society the systems and for
like just the systems of society are out
of balance because they are very
masculine leaning in what way like in
the way that they and who runs them or
like how it is run both both I think
greed and capitalism and is very like a
masculine
um at the expense of I mean maybe it's
not but I think it is like at the
expense of
the Earth and resources and maybe life
like human life and in getting a product
made and increasing profit margins and
you know enslaving children or raping
the Earth if it's minerals or you know
releasing lots of toxic stuff into the
air or into our food and all this stuff
I feel like that's not a feminine thing
to do not a nurturing thing to do
um so I think just like
there's a lot I mean there's obviously
so much I'm grateful for about
capitalism but then the imbalances that
were
the greed and the
um
lobbying that happens and
the buying of politicians and then they
have to keep up like I mean that's a
whole rabbit hole we got to go down but
so I think I think the the the
domination of men in power that's
obviously been enabled by A system that
is
created by men in power for I don't know
when that started it's been eons right
feel that the new paradigm is like we
need to go back to that
no there's a re-naturing that has to
happen the the masculine
patriarchy driven
um
system that we're living in has
disconnected us from nature and it's
called Mother Nature because it's
feminine like so we are genetically
modifying our food we are genetically
modifying our
DNA at this point we are
um
we are in addicted to screens and not
out in nature like we're we're
denaturing ourselves our food and our
our and and then we're raping our planet
so we're denaturing nature
um so I think that part of the big
rebalancing is bringing that feminine
um approach and nurturing and love and
holistic
um realizing that everything's involved
we can't go conscientiousness A
conscientiousness and A and a connection
to Nature and each other that's missing
right now because of this kind of
masculine profit at all costs Bottom
Dollar Bottom Dollar we've been
denatured
um by greed and Industry
um and this pressure and we're seeing it
in social media again
um like when at all costs get followers
at all costs and so now I think there's
going to be
um you know more females coming into
Power into the current system before the
system can change and then also just a
as as individually we become more
balanced doing the work of feminine and
masculine doing the Forgiveness work
um accepting ourselves
taking out our implants whatever it is
um you know then we'll see collectively
you know again I just love this idea of
like being more local being more in
community and and just that's that just
feels more feminine and connected what
do you think a woman's superpower is I
know that one of them is bringing a
freaking life into this world that's not
for every everybody but we are like a
portal for life that's crazy actually
yeah I did an interview and somebody was
like well the the most straightforward
portals like the portal that you can
create like you can create is like a
child a child's portal and I was like oh
my God totally I think love our capacity
to love and feel when [ __ ] goes down
lift a car off of a child like the the
we all have that maternal Instinct
whether you have children or not we we
feel this it's it's our love I think our
superpower is love and
I mean you are so like you came in with
so many gifts and you love
racing you know you loved competing you
but like your love for it drove you like
your love for
your curiosity is a version of love you
know like you're we're just I think our
superpower is love I think that
um we love our children we love our
friends we love our girlfriends we love
our husbands we love our
wives we love we just love so greatly
and that cause that allows us to do very
powerful things what is it that a man
needs to respect about a woman and what
is it a woman needs to respect about a
man that's challenged right now that
would bring us closer together
man I think that men
need to respect women's intelligence
more because I just feel like we have a
subtle intelligence
like intuition like intuition abilities
and empathy
that
will make us
I think some of the best leaders in the
world and I think we're starting to get
that shot where we haven't in history as
much but I think the intelligence that
women have
is a much more complex intelligence the
different intelligence different
intelligence intelligence and I think
that it can complement complement the
intelligence and and what what men have
been able to create
um but it's a different intelligence and
it's time for that intelligence to step
forward a little bit more so if men the
smartest men will recognize that and tap
into that all right now you got to flip
it you gotta I'm like a really like I
have so much Libra in me I'm like well
there's the man but there's the woman
like if we're going to talk about the
picture everybody talking about
matriarchy so what is it that we need to
respect and honor about men that is
challenged right now that they do really
well what's coming up for me is their
ability to survive like when [ __ ] goes
down they step up I mean I know the men
in my life too and that is what I
respect and admire again I'm getting
emotional why am I getting emotional I
just feel like times are freaking tough
right now and what I see with the men in
my life is they just they don't sit
around
they're not soft you know they're just
like I'm gonna [ __ ] figure it out
excuse my French there's some French
that needs to happen right now because
times are tough for everybody and
and it's all relative but like the
reason men are in power is because the
burden's been on them to survive and
keep the keep the the family unit
protected in the wild that's still in
them and that's
thank God for men in that way you know
and and again just like you said like we
have these wounds as children
um that no longer are relevant they're
irrational at this point because we're
bigger and more independent and can fend
for ourselves so we can let those go and
and
Nature has changed like we live in these
cities we're not fighting saber-toothed
tigers and and warring tribes but
there's still that instinct to survive
and and that's to be honored and
respected and and I'm grateful for that
you know if you like this clip and you
want to hear the whole episode click at
the bottom of your screen